Guys, I'm so amped I could stay here for three weeks.
Nine hours down and we're almost in the door.
I think two people just left.
Why would they be leaving when we're only nine hours away?
Yeah I mean, this is an event!
Uh-oh, blogs are saying the battery looks sketchy!
If it looks the same, how will people know I upgraded?
Is it 4G? Is it 4G? It doesn't say! It doesn't say!
Whoa! What has she got there?
Not sure.
What is that?
Guys, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Hey bro, could we see your phone?
Um, sure.
Can I see it with my hands?
Have you seen this thing?
Oh!
Check out the screen, this thing is huge.
It's pretty massive.
And it's got 4G speed.
It's magnificent.
Samsung.
Samsung?
That's a Samsung.
Yeah.
I could never get a Samsung.
I'm creative.
Dude, you're a barista.
Why don't you guys just get 4G phones?
Why don't you just get 4G phones?
Yeah, it's a Galaxy SII.
This phone is amazing.
The Galaxy SII...
...from Samsung.